الى الصين هذه المره التي توصل ابهارها
العسكري وتسير نحو اطلاق التجارب الاولى
لحامله طائراتها الجديده سفينه فوجيا
التجارب ستكون الاولى من نوعها لحامله
الطائرات الاكثر تطورا في تاريخ البحريه
الصينيه والتي تعد ايضا اكبر سفينه بحريه
صنعتها الصين على الاطلاق ويراهنوا الجيش
الصيني بشكل كبير على حامله الطائرات
لتعزيز اصوله البحري وياته اطلاق هذه
التجارب استكمالا للخطه التي اطلقها
الرئيس الصيني فيجن في الذكر المئويه
لتاسيس الحزب الشيوعي الصيني والتي تقوم
على تحديث المعدات العسكريه وستكون هذه
الخطوات الاولى في سلسله من التجارب تستمر
حوالي 18 شهرا على ان يتم تشغيل حامله
الطائرات الجديده بحلول اكتوبر 2004 2024
[موسيقى]